endlich hat man hier zwischen den
bayerischen orten albertshofen und
kitzingen einen dringend benötigten
radweg gebaut
parallel zur stark befahrenen
staatsstraße seit vielen jahren geplant
ist er jetzt befahrbar gut befahrbar
stimmt nicht ganz denn urplötzlich endet
das gute stück mitten auf dem acker weil
die stadt kitzingen sich weigert den weg
weiter zu bauen müssen die radler ab
hier wieder auf die gefährliche straße
wechseln und sind stinksauer ich bin
natürlich auch sehr erstaunt über diesen
radweg der im nirwana ende war es ein
absoluter erstens ich verstehe und
verständnis ich verstehe warum die da
sich so gegen weigern das zu machen
gleich nicht verstehen ist natürlich
eigentlich unverständlich warum man das
nicht machen kann für die fahrradfahrer
zwölf jahre planen die kommunen
albertshofen und kitzingen gemeinsam den
radweg passiert ist dann aber gar nichts
in diesem jahr precht albertshofen vor
und baut für 110000 euro bis an die
stadtgrenze
der rest bleibt unvollendet zwei
kommunen streiten sich und dann kommt am
ende so ein halber radweg r aus der
albert schäfer bürgermeister kennt die
schuldigen die amtskollegen aus
kitzingen die alberts hilfe sehen es
nicht als risiko verschwendetes geld an
sondern die sehen das eigentlich den
schwarzen peter bei der stadt kitzingen
weil sie mich mit machen seit eben zwölf
jahren davon will man im kissinger
rathaus nichts wissen die stadt wolle
die radweglücke als dann schließen wenn
die parallel verlaufende staatsstraße
saniert wird
für ein interview hatte der
oberbürgermeister keine zeit schriftlich
heißt es eher unkonkret beide maßnahmen
sollen hand in hand gehen aber für
diesen ausbau gibt es noch gar keine
konkrete planung und auch die
finanzierung ist noch nicht geklärt
die menschen in unterfranken können es
nicht fassen
und da ist man schon ein todeskandidat
auf der straße das sei nicht mehr
passiert es stau nicht gott sei dank ist
noch nichts passiert
aber sie sollten sich anstrengen dass
das fertig ist das auch nichts passiert
ich finde den großen sparen weil das ist
nicht nachvollziehbar das muss so 500
meter radweg nicht einfach mal zur
sicherheit bauen um die haarsträubende
situation etwas zu entschärfen plant man
in kitzingen für die radler jetzt eine
provisorische lösung über einen feldweg
bis es endlich einen durchgehenden
radweg von albertshofen nach kitzingen
gibt kann es aber noch bis zum sankt
nimmerleins tag dauern